there's always room for dessert here's a  sweet idea just for you  okay so i don't make dessert often so  you want to trust me when i say this  dulce de leche lava cake was epic first  you're going to crack an egg and an egg  yolk add your sugar and you're going to  beat it until it looks like that  you're going to add your juice elite to  a bowl with your butter melted bean  meringue and add it to the eggs with  your flour cinnamon  and grease your ramekin with butter add  a little sugar so it doesn't stick bake  them up then we're going to make our  little drizzle cream  run the knife through it so it comes off  smooth  add your ice cream your drizzle and  you're done  i'm going to be thinking about that all  day long  [Music]